I made my Korean acting debut for a soap
opera that's very popular here in South
Korea they asked me to use my face or a
green screen to be a pitch I really
don't know what's happening hey Chuck
Nana this big star
not just my co-star she's going to fall
in love with me it's every actress I've
never worked with falls in love with me
no rain sometimes ooh of China oh no no
when we do in a few arrow yagi - yum yum
I see yogi boom no no okay
no no no
[Applause]
I'm reading here and hopefully you can
find something here her name is Conan
O'Brien
Tabata Gavin give any kids on a sequel
or addition to having a good Saturday
Czech Silesia victim looking for a woman
who's five foot seven big beautiful eyes
a petite
a woman with a history it's you know one
Harlan Yahoo boomer young I won't join
your marriage service for what why yagi
chi hung up no I'm some town su of China
[Applause]
one thing to tell you sincerely love
overcomes everything
youngji mess ale
[Applause]
you